okay okay welcome everybody to the
second talk of today so here it uh are
you ready
news Maybe
it's one of echoing
uh actually I don't hear do
you
hear me
can you hear me now
okay I guess
if you hear me then I can
should I start
thanks okay I'm sorry about all the
audio glitches
uh but thanks for the patience
okay so we were uh talking about
um random walks on various dimensions
in the in a simplicial complex in a high
dimensional expander
and now I'm gonna look at these two
theorems that say that if a complex is a
link expander remember what this means
is that for every face you look just at
the local View
the part of the complex just above that
face and you look at the graph
underlying that part
that graph needs to be a Lambda expander
for every one of the links
this definition implies that complex is
a Lambda random walk expander and the
the definition of being Lambda random
walk is that the upper and the lower
random walks are very similar to each
other
when you remove the laziness component
okay so uh really this is an if and only
if except that in the only if you lose
some
some amount and I don't know
you know maybe
very likely that this can be improved
but I don't know what is the best best
possible connections here so that's
something to explore
anyway let's just look at this uh first
part which says if you know you're a
link expander
you can deduce that you're a random walk
expander and this direction is proved
very useful it was used in the
Breakthrough result of showing that a
certain Markov chains or an
exponentially large State space
converging polynomial time this is by
anari luo viscaran and vinzan showing
that the basis exchanging
very random walk converges I'll talk
about that so anyway let's first prove
the theorem if you're a link expander
then you're a random walk expander so
let's start and really the proof is
again using or showing the local to
Global principle that underlies a lot of
this area and showing that if you know
something about the links you can do
something much more global
okay so we start with a function in CI
so it's a really valued function on the
I faces
and uh
I need to be the dimension I need to be
smaller than D so that we have room to
go up we need to say something about the
upper random walk being similar to the
lower render Mark that is the conclusion
we are looking for
okay we want to show that X is a Lambda
random mock HDX so that upper random
mock is similar to the lower ending
okay so this is what we need to show
that Mi Plus
uh if inner palette with F this
quadratic form is upper bounded by
UD F inner product F UD is the lower end
mark you go down D and then up
plus some error term which is the
Lambda I guess sometimes I called it
Lambda sometimes gamma but it's it's
this it's the same
okay
um
all right okay maybe I'll change let's
see if I change it and hope I don't run
into a lot of trouble okay
um so first let's write down the
expression for a a the run the Mi Plus
so basically it's an inner product and I
faces
my faces so you take a random I face and
then you write F of s
times this whole expression is really m
i plus F of s and what this is is you
need to take expectation over go first
up to a t just above s
and then you go back down to it S Prime
just below T but you need to take care
of the S Prime is not equal to s
and that's kind of the random neighbor
you go to when you do Mi plus and you
average F on this random neighbor S
Prime
so this is just kind of spelling out the
definition of Mi Plus
and now we want to write it slightly
differently so let's uh first see that
this distribution is the same as if we
first chose T the one dimension higher
face and then we chose two faces below
it S and S Prime
so it's it's just the same distribution
first you choose say if you want you can
think of the situation where I equals
one so you're walking from edge to edge
first you're walking from Edge to
Triangle to Edge and later we'll walk
from Edge to vertex to Edge so then you
first
here you first choose an edge then you
choose a triangle containing the edge
then you choose another Edge in this
triangle that's not the original one
and it's the same distribution as if you
first choose
an i plus one phase a triangle for
example and then choose two eye faces
oops inside of it one Edge and another
Edge
okay it's exactly the same and now uh
look at this drawing that's supposed to
help us
um
this circle here is supposed to be the
entire face T so it's an i plus one face
it has I plus two vertices in it
and I chose a one choice of s is just
removing some element from T So T oops T
minus X and then S Prime is some other I
face so it's removing some other element
y
okay this new feature of notability I'm
not not yet adapted to it so uh it's S
Prime so basically what you're doing is
you have a i plus one phase one first
time you remove X second time you remove
y
and let's look at the remaining part
this let's call it r
so to choose T and then SNS Prime is
equivalent to First choose r
the remaining part then enlarge it to T
by choosing some random uh
X Y such that together with X Y
you get a face this is just the same as
if you first choose the face r
and then you choose a random Edge from
the link of R right because what is a
random Edge from the lingovar the edges
in the link of R are exactly coming from
faces that contain r that when you
remove R from them you are left with an
edge so this is a the conclusion of this
is that choosing T S and S Prime is the
same as choosing first
oops
apologies it's the same as I guess let's
do it this way first choosing R and then
choosing
an edge in the link of r
and then R Union X is S and R Union Y is
S Prime so so far we only have equality
okay now this is interesting we started
from s going up and going to S Prime but
now we have something below we have R
which is actually an i minus 1 phase so
we can now look at this whole
expectation from the r's right so what's
going on now for every R let's Define f
sub r
at a point x to b f at R Union X okay so
now we have a function just on the
vertices of the link
XR
we had a function on the I faces and now
we have a function on the vertices of
the link XR
okay so now with this notation this
expression just becomes the
quadratic form AR FR inner product FR
where AR is the adjacency Matrix of the
link of XR
okay again still equality
so now
we can use the fact that we know
something about the expansion of the
links we actually know that AR is a very
good expander
so this inner product a r f r f r is
pretty similar to another inner product
where instead of AR we can write
you know the J the the kind of complete
graph the quadratic
and okay so this is exactly the gamma
link expansion so here I see that I
still have gamma
I'm not gonna get away with this so
let's
interchange gamma and Lambda okay sorry
about that
it's the same number for us
okay so uh so by our assumption that you
know the one-sided assumption says that
AR is order
U d0 this is just another notation for J
uh
this is just another annotation for the
for J and then plus the error term which
is gamma
so we get this thing this expression
and now
remember we said that U and D are a are
joined to each other so I can take this
U and move it here
and I will get the d f time in a product
DF so this is just
DF at point R
it's basically
you average all the points of f sub R
and then you take the square of this
average this is exactly what the Matrix
J does
so this term just gives me DF r squared
and this term when I take expectation
over R I get just the two Norm of f all
together
and so all in all what I got is the
lower random walk
UD oops F inner product f plus this
error term which is exactly what we
wanted to get so we saw that to bound a
mi plus F comma f
from here we ended up with the lower and
the walk plus this error term and we did
it by locally at the links having the
same kind of inequality so it globalized
so that's really like a proof that
writes writes itself
okay
now let's look at this application to
The Matrix
basis exchange random walk okay
so this is another example of a
simplicial complex that I didn't didn't
describe to you so let me describe it
now maybe to
I should have
kind of erased stuff so that
we don't get distracted okay so we're
gonna now not look at General Metroid
because then I would have to Define it
instead I'm gonna just look at the
following a random walk that moves from
spanning tree to spanning tree in a
given graph okay so I'm starting with
sound graph G okay with n vertices and
images
and I'm building a simplicial complex
what is my simplicial complex well the
vertices of this complex are going to be
e the edges of the graph
okay so M vertices
and it's going to be a high dimensional
complex the dimension is going to be n
minus 2 because the top dimensional
faces are n minus two faces these are
sets of n minus 1 edges
only those sets that form a spanning
tree in the graph
okay so we defined a bunch of the faces
like this
and now that I defined the N minus two
faces I take all their subsets I close
downwards and every a forest or every
every
subgraph that has no Loops it always can
be completed to a tree so it's it's a
phase in our
in our complex X so that's the
definition of a complex and now uh
here's a random one you start from some
arbitrary spanning tree
and you start changing it how do you
change it well you go down
when you go down what are you doing
you're erasing an edge from the spanning
tree
okay so now you have two components now
you can add some Edge there's maybe more
than one possibility so you add it and
you keep going like this
what is going to happen are you going to
reach any other spanning tree so
actually you can easily think about it
and you'll see that yes you will reach
every other spanning tree
but how fast will you randomly you want
to converge to kind of a random spanning
free Hub how fast will that happen I
mean there could be an exponential
number of spanning trees
okay so this is how we're gonna now use
the uh
the theorem that says if
you study your links and you know that
you have a good link expander then
you'll be able to deduce that the random
walk converges
okay so let's now look at these pictures
so I took this graph I'm sorry that the
picture is so weird and I'm starting
from some spanning tree so the blue
edges are
spanning Tree in this graph
now I want to understand the links
so my top faces are spanning trees well
I can look at the link of one below so
when you erase one Edge but that's like
uh it's
like looking just at the one dimension
before the top it's not interesting the
link of such an object has just a bunch
of vertices
so that's not interesting when does the
link become interesting when the
dimension is too below so you need to go
from n minus 2 to n minus 4. so here is
for example a an N minus a four phase
over here I took a spanning tree this
one and I erased two edges from it right
which ones did I erase I guess oh well
I erased this one and this one
right
okay so I raised two two uh faces permit
so now I'm in a n minus
a co-dimension to a phase so it's the
top Dimension minus two
phase and now let's look at the link of
this thing so I'm doing it by example
but you'll see the idea so
um
I need to understand the link of this
thing so remember the vertices of our
complex are the edges
so who are the vertices in the link
they're all the possible ways of
extending this Forest into a spanning
tree so basically I should never add an
edge that's inside a component this is
not allowed but any Edge that crosses
between components is allowed so I have
these two edges that cross between
component one and three so you see here
that I have three components right one
two and three
and now I have two edges Crossing from
one to three two edges between one and
two and actually Four edges between two
and three
okay
so the vertices in my link are these
um are these edges so I have two edges
these are oops these are vertices in my
link
so I have two ah
okay two of the red kind two of the blue
kind and four of the purple kind okay so
these are you know two plus two plus
four vertices in my link now who are the
edges in my link
so what is an edge in the link I'm gonna
allow myself to connect
a you know one of the vertices to
another one of the vertices if both of
them together live in a spanning tree so
when will two edges live together in a
spanning tree well once I add say the
edge between component one and component
three I'm no longer going to be allowed
to add another one another Edge between
these two components so this Edge cannot
be in a standing tree with this Edge but
it can certainly be in a spanning tree
with any one of the other edges
right because if I add this and this I
have a tree and if I add this and that I
also have a tree
so this Edge you know one of these two
is actually connected to all the other
edges except for the red ones
so all in all what you have here is a
three-partite graph between the you know
the red the blue and the purple and you
know every every edge of the two three
kind is connected to every edge of the
one three kind and every edge of the one
two kind
so what you have here in the link this
is the structure of the link and it
doesn't matter which you know which to
edges I erased it's always going to be a
three-partite graph the size of the part
is not always the same
that's the only variability we have
and if you look at the second largest
eigenvalue of this graph it will be a
zero or less than or at one zero I don't
remember exactly but definitely no more
than zero
and so by the trickle down theorem that
we saw
even when you go down in the links
if you started with zero then zero
divided by one minus zero is still going
to be zero and so you get it the entire
complex will have expanding links all
the way down we only looked at the top
links
and so by the uh because of this
actually maybe you don't even need that
it's enough to have link expansion at
that level to know that the random walk
on this level converges to
um
you know very fast like
the the Gap there is polynomial in the
dimension so it's going to be 1 over n
maybe or something like that so in
polynomial in many steps you're gonna
reach a random expanding tree so of
course this is a bit hand-waving but you
get the the heart of the idea of this
beautiful result that uses the analysis
and the links to to show that a random
walk converges
okay now I want to talk a little bit
about the deposits
uh okay so so far I talked a lot about
simplicial complexes in most of the
theory of high dimension and expansion
was developed in this context and
there's two reasons I think one is that
it kind of grew out of this
lsv complexes these ramanujan complexes
that are simplicial and two which is
probably more basic is that the notion
of a link is the most natural and kind
of pretty
in the simplicial world because then you
can really remove a vertex and you'll
still have a face and so
the things they work out nicely but a
simplicial situation is respective and a
lot of high dimensional objects are not
simplicial
you can think of more General situations
and I think if opposite is one a
possibility
uh so we're gonna
copy the same kind of a picture that we
had for the simplicial complex where we
had a x x minus 1 was some trivial
element and then we had elements of rank
zero
in the simplicial world these were
vertices but we can have another
opposite for example the positive linear
subspaces so this would be Zero
Dimensional subspaces maybe I find like
points in a vector space and then you
can have the elements of rank one for
example affine lines and then you can
have elements of rank two I find planes
that's one example of a positive another
example of a posit we have these objects
called the cubical complexes where you
don't have triangles but rather you have
vertices edges squares cubes and so on
so that also gives rise naturally to a
posit partially ordered set maybe I
should have said
and a lot of the things that we were
looking at we can just as well Define on
posit so first you can certainly Define
the up and down operators right when you
want to you have a function on the I
faces
these are the elements of rank I in your
ranked posset then you can
apply a down operator and create a
function on the i-1 faces where you
define the function on some I minus one
phase by averaging the function on all
the elements above your element and you
can also apply a the done operator
similarly or the app operator similarly
sorry and you can define a random walk
where you start from an element you go
up then you go down then you go up and
you go down so everything that we did
you can
do in a random walk part you can do on a
positive
and
a nice part of the Theory actually
carries over to this to this setup so
not going to talk about it anymore I
just wanted to say that
for example you can find a fourier-like
basis for functions on the eye faces
using the same ideas
and you can Define what it means to be a
high dimensional expanding faucet
okay so now in the last part of the talk
I do want to talk a little bit about the
second kind of expansion
um
that is studied in the area of high
dimensional expansion and this is
co-boundary and systolic expansion
now it used to be maybe a few years ago
that we said we uh we would hear a talk
about high dimensional expanders and the
talk would begin like this it would say
you know for expander graphs there are
multiple definitions there's a
combinatorial definition of edge
expansion there's a spectral definition
there's a random walk definition and so
on and so on
and they're all the same for graphs but
somehow they all convert diverge to
different definitions when you
generalize them in higher Dimensions but
somehow things are a bit less Divergent
these days and I think there's two main
kind of types of definitions the first
one is the ones we've been talking about
so far link expansion random walk
expansion and we saw that they're
related
although the relationship is not
completely
clear there are some questions
and there's a different type of
expansion which is this one and this has
to do much more with the
topology it's kind of homological and it
has to do with linear algebra so the way
to think about it I think is you use the
geometric structure of the complex
to create
certain linear algebraic Maps Okay you
use the incident structure to Define
certain linear Maps so now you're
working say over the finite field like
F2
you can work over many different
coefficient spaces not not only F2 but
F2 is a good place to start
and then you define these Maps this
Delta and this partial
and you know the where the tail goes
supposed to indicate to you like you
know how
Delta the tail goes this way so you're
going up whereas partial of the tail
goes this way so you're going down
so really this is like an app
and this is like a Down
and the formula for defining Delta f is
exactly the same formula that we had for
the app operator so let's see what's
going on firstly we Define the I chains
now it's not like we did before
previously CI was the set of all
functions from the I faces to Reels now
we're looking at CI
is just the set of well let me even
write it this way it's just F2 to the x
i
but I could have written as the set of
all functions from x i to F2 it's the
same
so it's almost like we had before except
now we replace the reels
with F2
okay but somehow this changes a lot so
Delta takes me from an i chain function
on the I faces to an i plus one chain it
moves me up and this Delta part the
partial takes me
this is the boundary map it takes me
from an i chain to an i minus one chain
so this is called the boundary map
and this is called the co-boundary so
somehow
boundaries may be more intuitive but
co-boundary is where all the interesting
things happen
so uh talk about it some more uh now but
I want to just say that
in
it's somehow more mysterious than the
previous part of my talk
um
these Maps we already saw that they're
useful you can get from them locally
testable codes and kind of interesting
definitions of codes you can get from
the quantum low
density parity check codes so there's
some interesting things happening with
these Maps but they're much more
mysterious and also they're related to
these topological Notions that uh
have you know topologies have good
intuition for them
when you're working over you know the
complex numbers or the reals and less
intuition when you're working over F2
so it's kind of
a good a good area to if you're a
student and you're starting it's a good
area to enter because
it's growing there we don't yet
understand what's going on so there is
maybe a lot of things to discover
okay so let's let's do some definitions
right so I already wrote the bound
sorry
yeah
okay
I'll be back just a minute
apologies Okay so
the boundary in the code in the
co-boundary operator we
describe them
and
let's for example Focus just on the
co-boundary operator
okay it's it's a lot of things so it's
best to restrict our focus a little bit
so we're going to be talking now about
the co-boundary operator so what's going
on is you have an eye chain so F gives
you a bit for every I face you can think
of I equals one for example so F gives
you a bit on every Edge
and now you're applying Delta so you're
gonna get now a bit on every triangle
and for a triangle what is the bit that
you're gonna get well you're gonna sum
the bits on the three edges so
previously we said let's average the
numbers on the three edges but now we're
working over F2 so we're just going to
sum them mod 2. okay so every triangle
now has really the core of the three
bits of the three edges
okay that's what Delta does
okay now something interesting happens
which is that when you apply Delta twice
suppose you start from a function say on
the vertices you apply Delta ones you
get a function on the edges you apply
Delta again
on what you got you get a function on
the triangles
but now
you will get zero
what's going on is that every value will
be added twice so somehow they will
cancel everything will cancel and you
will get zero okay and this is something
that is inherent in in this entire
Theory this is what makes a chain
complex so you get this sequence of
arrows people like to draw it like this
and the meaning of this chain of two
arrows is that the image
the image of Delta I minus 1 so you
start from something over here you apply
Delta once
you get something that's in the image of
Delta I minus 1. and there's a name for
this guy this is called bi this is
called sorry b i minus one
b i
sorry this is called bi so why is it
called bi bi are things that come from
one layer below these are the
co-boundaries B is for boundary or
co-boundary
and the index I indicates that I'm
sitting inside level I so these elements
are I
put chains
okay so I started from CI minus one I
move one I'm now in the image in bi now
I take my element that is in bi and I
apply Delta once more
okay I'm gonna reach zero so that means
the time in
the kernel
of Delta I
okay and this guy is called z i
okay so these are just names bi is a
name for the image of Delta and z i is a
name for the kernel of the next Delta
okay these are called let me say these
are called the co so it's a bunch of
words
it's not important to remember them
right now go boundaries
but I'll say them just once so you know
and these are co-cycles okay so for me
I think the important thing to think
about first time you hear about these
things is that
you have here a chain of two maps and
you know that the image of the first is
inside the telnet of the second now how
to think about it
one way to think about it is that
a being in the image of a map
gives you kind of there's an explicit
way of constructing these guys you take
something in CI minus one you apply the
map and you get something in the image
being in the kernel of a map
is an implicit definition you need to
find something I don't know how
and when you apply the map you're
supposed to get zero so you're sort of
you need to find something in the kernel
of the map okay so it's it's it's harder
to do
right
I mean if it's a linear map you can do
it in the quadratic or time but in
general kind of being in the kernel is
something that's a
less explicit in being in the image
Okay so
uh okay that's one thing now we'll give
some examples so sometimes uh actually
bi equals the I in this case
you have two different descriptions of
the same space one as an image of
something and one is a kernel of
something but sometimes they're actually
not equal
and then you define the quotient space
and this is the alcohol
okay this is the the space of elements
that are really new there are items in
the in the candle that don't have a
pre-image they're really like new things
that come up
okay so this is the chromology
okay so so far it's not very meaningful
but let's look at a few examples that
connect between these after closings and
really nice combinatorial properties
that we are familiar with
okay so let's say let's just calculate a
few examples
uh first maybe uh if there's any
questions then
okay
all right so let's uh let's
start with a few examples but I want to
say the following thing
in general you will see in in many
situations in topology or in math you
will see a sequence of arrows like this
and it's called the
chain complex so it's like if you see
just one Arrow you have a linear map
if you have a sequence of arrows it's
like a high dimension a linear map just
like
you know a if you have a graph you have
like The Arrow from vertices to edges
but if you have now a two-dimensional
graph then you have vertices edges and
triangles so you have like to
two uh two arrows so this is more
General you you can have a sequence of
arrows for linear maps and this is
called a chain complex but we are
focused on a much smaller sub area of
this where
our chain of maps they come from some
geometric object we have a high
dimensional expander we have a
simplicial complex
you know some combinatorial object like
all the ones we saw you know with the
macroids or with the spherical building
or you know or this say fish guide so
you have some complete sorry concrete
simplicial complex and you use this
object to Define your chain of linear
Maps okay and that's really cool because
you can then use the geometry
and also you can use like analytic power
that you've learned from studying random
walks and from studying link expansion
to reason about these linear maps and
this is really what's going on you you
know we're used to it that when we study
I don't know pcps or a constraint
satisfaction problems we study discrete
discrete objects using a you know real
analysis right so the same thing is
going on here you you have this linear
Maps they're defined on this geometric
object and you study them
both by using linear algebra and also by
using
uh you know analysis
so
we're not really going to see it in this
talk but maybe in Max's talk we'll see
so okay let's let's now again so now
we're doing examples so in our mind we
should think of we have some simplicial
complex some picture you know with
vertices and edges and maybe I have it
down here yeah here is an example you
know you have vertices and edges and so
on
and maybe I'll move it so you can have
it in our in our minds
like this okay
and now we're gonna we're gonna
understand what these Deltas do on this
object
okay
so my spaces are going to be C minus one
this is all the functions on faces of
Dimension minus one so there's only one
phase of Dimension minus one it's the
empty set
so is C to the minus one this is just
equal to
F2
to the
you know Singleton so it's just F2
okay and c0 is F2
to the X zero right so it's uh
X zero
okay so it's like all the zero one
labelings of vertices and and so on okay
so now let's look at my first example
I'm here suppose I have some function in
c0 so this function gives me a zero one
value for every vertex
and since it gives me a zero one value
for every vertex I can use the letter
capital S to say this is the set of
vertices that get a one and the other
vertices get a zero okay so my function
really indicates some set of vertices
like you know maybe it indicates this
set of vertices
now what is Delta F so I don't really
need to write 0 because I know that f is
in c0 but if I want I want to calculate
what is Delta 0 of f
so Delta 0 takes me from C 0 to C1 so
it's a function on edges and I need to
know uh for every Edge I need to
calculate the function on this Edge it's
really the sum modular 2 of f on this
vertex plus F on this vertex okay so
suppose that my function how should I do
this
yeah
suppose that my my function f
was you know is it was one on this set
and just these three vertices two three
four
by the way in this picture it misleading
because
uh
two and three are depict are pictured
here twice okay
because the picture closes
but anyway suppose this is my set s the
vertices two three four and now I want
to know what is the Delta zero of a so
it's really well this Edge
gets one plus one so it's zero
this Edge gets zero and this Edge gets
zero
all these edges that go from the set to
outside of the set
and they get one
so all these sets get one
all these edges and all the edges like
these guys that are totally outside of
the set again they get zero so really
what's going on is that it's the
indicator
of the cut
between S and S complement
do you see that for every Edge that has
one endpoint in s and one end point
outside of us you get a one otherwise
you get a zero
so the co-boundary of a set is a cut
so that's nice
so the set of all core boundaries b0 the
image of Delta zero is the set of oil
cuts by this I mean the set of all
functions of the edges that indicate a
cut
okay so this is b0 now let's do another
example
let's take some function in C minus one
remember C minus 1 is really just a bit
because I just need to say what value
I'm giving the empty set so either zero
or one
so now what is Delta minus 1 of f so let
me just write
minus one here so Delta minus 1 is for
every vertex I'm moving now from the
empty set to the vertices for every
vertex I need to take
the empty set and Summit well I just
copy the value so if it was zero every
vertex gets a zero so I get all zero
function and if it was one every vertex
gets a one that's it so the set b0 b0
yeah I guess I should have called this
guy B1 sorry this goes wrong this is B1
because my convention is that the index
says where you are living so these are
functions on the edges so they are B1
over here whereas these are functions
and the vertices there will be zero so
b0 is just the constant all zero
function or the constant all ones
function that's it
okay and is another example let's look
at this is V zero these are the
co-cycles the kernel of Delta zero okay
so these are functions in the vertices
such that when you apply Delta to them
you get a zero so Delta of a function on
the vertices as a function on the edges
Delta of u v needs to be zero and this
is equal to F of U plus F of e so what
does that mean functions on the vertices
so that for every Edge F of U plus F of
V equals zero so for every Edge if F of
U is one F of V must be one and F of w
must be one and so on and so on the
entire connected component needs to have
the same value
okay so really what's going on here is f
is in this calendar of Delta zero if it
is constant on each connected component
if the graph is connected F just needs
to be constant so it's going to exactly
equal V zero right v0 was the set just
containing the constant functions
okay so if the graph is connected we get
that the zeroth chronology
remember we defined it to be
Z zero divided by b0 the difference
between coming from below and being in
the candle of the next this is just zero
if if the graph is connected if it's
disconnected then they're not the same
so the commonology measure is kind of
this being not connected
sometimes people like to say it measures
the holes
but this is intuition that's more
correct for real valid functions and
less so for F2 I think
okay now let's let's uh let's look at
this example which is I think a bit
interesting uh let's look at this graph
that I copied from upstairs
now I'm gonna move it back
let's look at this graph oops
I don't know why that is okay never mind
okay look at this graph and I asked
myself
I my claim is that this function that's
highlighted the yellow
it's a function on the edges right it's
a function that's one and all the yellow
edges and zero on all the other edges
now my claim is that it's a core cycle
meaning that when you apply Delta to it
move it up to the triangles you're gonna
get zero let's check this
so for example on this triangle
when you apply Delta you're summing the
function on all three edges
but since you have two edges with a one
and one edge with a zero you're going to
get a zero so you get zero here
you're going to get zero and all of
these
what about on this triangle of course
you're going to get zero right because
you've got zero plus zero plus zero so
Delta of this function indeed is zero so
it's a cost cycle now the question is is
it a co-boundary we know that B1
is contained always in Z1
and
but is this a core boundary
okay well
if it needs to if it's a co-boundary it
must mean that you know
one of the end points of this Edge
must be inside
there's going to be a set of vertices so
that when you apply Delta to it you get
our function that's what it means to be
a co-boundary it means that it's Delta
of some function on the vertices so we
start with this suppose it's this guy it
could have been this one but let's
assume it's this guy then this is this
one is in let me actually use
this one must be inside so this one is
outside
so this one must be inside outside
inside outside I reached a contradiction
because I I wanted this guy to be inside
and now I got that it's outside this is
the same vertex and if you try the other
one you'll get the same thing so in this
case uh for this complex you actually
have
a non-trivial cycle that's not a
covaluary in general you can have much
more interesting things
okay
okay all right so now that we have some
warm up let's
um
try to define a co-boundary expansion
I know we're getting to the end of the
lecture and I know it's a bit abstract
and
uh okay and I hope it still makes sense
to you guys
[Music]
um
all right so
I want to talk about a commander
expansion and the first thing that I
want to say is that
it's also a generalization of edge
expansion so I defined in the beginning
of the previous hour
what does it mean for a graph to be a
spectral expansion I didn't even Define
Edge expansion but we've all seen it
this is a definite one of the
definitions of edge expansion basically
says if I have a graph G
The Edge expansion is the minimum
a size of a bottleneck so a bottleneck
is like you cut the graph into two
pieces SNS complement
and you look at how many edges cross
between SNS complement this is this part
and you divide it by the size of s when
you think of s as being the smaller part
but really you're dividing by the
minimum of S and S complement
so this is a standard definition of edge
expansion and now we can rewrite it in a
weird homological way but it's actually
exactly equal so that's kind of cool
so what's going on here now I'm looking
not at a subset of vertices but rather
at a function on the vertices
that is not in b0 so what is B zero it's
the constant functions right let me
scroll up and hope that that's what we
got
right this is b0
these are the functions that came from
the -1 dimensional phase
okay so I'm looking at a function on the
vertices that is not constant this is
the same as saying a subset that is not
a trivial subset it's not the empty set
and it's not the complete set
okay and now what I'm measuring is the
weight of Delta F now what is Delta F
it's exactly the cut
that is created from
the vertices that get a one two the
vertices that get a zero so it's exactly
the size of Delta f is exactly oops the
the edges that are counted when you
count how many edges cross the cut so
this is exactly equal to this and
finally
uh we are looking at the distance
between our function
and b0 b0 is this the constant functions
does
the all ones are all zero so what is the
distance of my function between from the
o0 and all ones well if the function has
a
less than half per ones then the closer
one will be the all zeros and you're
just going to measure how many ones if
the function has more than half ones the
closer function will be this one and the
distance will be
how many zeros so it's really just the
size of either s or S complement
so
I managed to parse all of this notation
and show you that it's exactly the same
thing but now I want to explain it in a
way that makes sense so it's not just
about rewriting this notation there's
actually meaning here so I want to
explain it
hey what's going on here is that this
definition makes sense when Z 0 equals
b0 so
all the functions that are in the kernel
of of Delta are actually functions that
oh it's correct a of Delta
1 actually functions that come from
Below
yeah so we're talking here in this case
this just means as we said that the
graph is connected we said that when the
graph is connected then b0 equals v0 so
in this case
what we're trying to do is not only ask
a
you know is our is our function constant
or not we're actually trying to
understand you know
how far is it or how close is it to a
constant function and the way we're
going to do it is we're gonna choose a
random Edge
and compute Delta on it so we're just
gonna see if the two endpoints of this
Edge are equal
and the probability that they're equal
is exactly measured by the weight of
Delta F so you can think of this as a
test
for whether the function is a constant
this is in the top part of the quotient
and in the bottom part you are looking
at the distance of f from in this case
the constant so really this is like a
property testing for being inside this
set this is kind of a non-interesting
set so it's a bit of a leap to to see it
but the point is that you have this
property
and you can test if your function is
inside this property by looking at a
random Edge and and seeing if the two
endpoints are equal now if your graph is
connected then this test is a little bit
good because you know
there if the function is not a constant
there is at least one Edge that we'll
notice but if your graph is like a long
path there might be only one Edge that
will notice this
and but if your graph is an expander a
constant fraction of the edges we'll
notice at least in relation to how far
your function is from constant okay so I
didn't say it very nicely and I only
have five minutes so let me move on just
to the more General because this is
where it becomes more interesting
um
yeah
in greater generality
you're looking at this chain of arrows
this said
yeah I want to draw it here so I have
the
I have I don't see I minus one and then
I apply Delta and I get to CI and then I
apply Delta again and I get to CI plus
one okay so this is the picture I have
in mind and now what I'm what I'm
looking at when I look at this
expression
over here I'm looking at I have a
function if it's in CI it's over here
I apply Delta to it
so Delta you know it's the snap for
example if the function is on the edges
then for every triangle you sum up three
things so it's a very very local map it
just looks at F on three queries kind of
source them in checks and the weight of
Delta f is how often you get a non-zero
okay this is like the test is rejecting
it's not it's supposed to be zero if it
was all zero then you would actually be
you know in the kernel like here oh yeah
but this is rejecting sometimes so you
have some non-zero
uh
points and you want this to be
comparable to how far you are from uh
being a you know a perfect solution that
Maps exactly to zero so really what's
going on here is that you think of this
as some kind of a property and you're
comparing your distance to the property
versus how much the test rejects or
doesn't
reject so I'm sorry that I I skipped a
bit fast now but um
the takeaway from this is as follows
um
or the case of I equals zero
the definition of co-boundary expansion
this quotient that I have over here
is exactly
um coinciding with Edge expansion
now when you increase I and you move to
functions on the edges on triangles and
so on you get something that looks
completely new and it was studied in
different contexts like it was studied
for a property called the topological
overlap by glomov and
and now we know that it's connected to a
and you know distance of quantum codes
for example but uh in a really cute
paper in Watson Kaufman showed that
really what's going on is that this
definition is a definition of property
testing it's showing that if this
quantity this h i is lower bounded say
it's a constant it means that you can
measure the distance of f to your
property and I know I have your two
definitions one is the distance to z i
one is the distance to bi and I'm not
going to go into it now
you can measure the distance of your
function to some complicated property by
doing this test by Computing Delta at a
random point and checking if it's one or
not
okay so it's like the commander
expansion of the complex is equivalent
to
property testing of this specific
property and somehow this leads to these
locally testable codes into
a lot of the interesting
things and
okay and I guess that's all like I have
time to say now and
and thanks for your attention I know
this is a bit the kind of a off to the
side of the focus of our semester but
then
maybe I can also comment it when you try
to prove you know property testing you
want to prove a
you know you want to prove say a lower
bound on hi for certain complexes like
for the spherical building for example
that we saw or for other things
to prove these things you really the way
we know how to do it you really rely on
all these analytic tools random walks
spectral bounds so there's no it's not a
coincidence that these two things live
on the same object you kind of want to
use all the power from both these
different
definitions
okay I guess if there are questions I'm
happy to take them
thank you very much any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
so any questions from the audience
I was wondering if there's uh
connections between co-bounder expansion
and spectral expansion in particular if
you have you know very strong Commander
expansion
can that imply spectral expansion is
there anything known of that kind okay
great thanks for the question
um
yeah there's a few things
uh one really interesting result
of the wounded and Wagner
it shows kind of a disconnect between
the two they give a complex
where you have great spectral expansion
but no co-boundary expansion or even
nocosystemic expansion
so that's kind of a
too bad
but
on the other hand you know celebrated
theorem of a government lubotsky and
also a Frank houseman
show
that if you know
spectral expansion in the links
and you know
co-boundary expansion in the links
then you can deduce I want to say Global
co-boundary expansion but you can't you
can deduce Global systolic expansion
like you see here that I have I haven't
kind of
talked about the difference between the
two but basically let's think of them as
the same so you do have this local to
Global
um theorem
but which uses
the Spectrum but it also uses the local
linear algebraic thing
yeah and kind of one wonders uh you know
this result of the gundel in Wagner that
gives a kind of a counter example maybe
there's a way around it so I don't know
any more questions from the audience
do you know if there are any
applications of expansion like uh
spectral expansion to topology like I
don't know to Upper bound the dimensions
of the commology groups and stuff like
that
yeah so maybe I should have said that
actually thanks
um you know this trickle down theorem
which is the first theorem that I showed
it shows you how spectral expansion in
the links a implies spectral expansion
of the global lay underlying graph
so really what you know people that know
attribute this tune to Gala and from the
70s
and I mean he didn't prove it in this
generality he proved it for a more
specific complex where we tried to and
he succeeded to show that the real value
comology vanishes and used the expansion
of the links so he did it exactly on
these uh brought its buildings that are
like what we talked about the ramanujian
complexes where the links are spherical
buildings so you know you have good
expansion there and he proved that the
commonology
but it's really valuable integer valued
commology vanishes I don't know if
that's what you meant in any way
it was a good answer I wonder if there's
something similar for small set
expansion
it would be something to investigate
this semester yes
thank you normal
any last questions
okay if so let's thank you it again
[Applause]
thank you and have a great semester it's
see you so thank you Rita so we'll
attend after lunch when Mom will be
speaking